vemos que hay recelo por parte de
ucrania y eslovaquia al embargo de la
compra de petróleo ruso debido a que
dependen altamente de él podría ello
limitar de alguna manera nuevos paquetes
de sanciones que los europeos puedan
imponer a rusia
claramente si la unión europea no está
de acuerdo de manera unánime no se puede
imponer un paquete de sanciones que
incluya embargo al petróleo y al gas
natural
además es muy probable que se lleguen a
acuerdos parciales es decir que haya un
acuerdo para un embargo en el carbón
otro para el petróleo y finalmente si se
pudiese llegar a un acuerdo sobre el gas
natural que es lo más difícil ya que la
unión europea importa prácticamente
150 bcm de gas anualmente de rusia
el señor la calle la ministra francesa
de la transición ecológica reconoció hoy
que no se puede reemplazar todo el gas
ruso con otras fuentes de energía dijo
que los europeos deben cambiar la manera
como producen energía y calientan sus
hogares qué posibilidades hay de una
transición en estos aspectos
bueno tenemos que entender que desde el
punto de vista de la matriz energética
de la unión europea' por un lado en la
unión europea' está prohibido el
desarrollo de las reservas domésticas de
gas es lo que se llama fracking por lo
tanto eso ya es algo que limita la
capacidad de la unión europea de ser
menos dependiente del gas de rusia
segundo las energías renovables la
eólica y la solar son muy intermitentes
volátiles e inclasificables por lo tanto
cuando hay poca poco viento o poco sol
lo que ocurre por su póster es que se
depende mucho más del gas y suele ser
claramente las épocas en las que hay
mayor nivel de demanda finalmente el
problema es que alemania por ejemplo
eliminó gran parte de su parque nuclear
con lo cual en la unión europea es muy
difícil buscar alternativas al gas ruso
entre otras cosas porque ha habido una
serie de errores de política energética
por parte de alemania en este caso al
eliminar las nucleares por parte de
otros países al limitar la capacidad de
acceder a recursos domésticos y claro la
también muy complicada posición en
cuanto a la importación de gas natural
licuado de otros países recordemos que
este invierno la unión europea se ha
salvado de un importante problema de
suministro gracias precisamente al gas
que se ha importado de eeuu que se
produce con la técnica de franklin por
lo tanto es una situación muy difícil y
desde luego no se puede solucionar a
corto plazo ni mucho menos solamente con
renovables y la unión europea va a tener
que hacer grandes cambios por eso está
dificultad para llegar a acuerdos en
cuanto a un embargo a rusia porque no
olvidemos en cualquier caso que si la
unión europea lleva a cabo un embargo a
rusia en cuanto a gas natural a petróleo
y carbón
a por ejemplo pues a china o al resto de
países de asia a propósito de este
cambio que usted menciona europa habla
de un proceso de adaptación para lograr
desprenderse de la energía rusa pero hay
tiempo cuánto puede tomar estos
preparativos muy brevemente por favor
claramente más de una década estamos
hablando de un proceso de eliminación de
un suministrador muy importante sería
imposible hacerlo a corto plazo
absolutamente imposible y no olvidemos
muchísimo más cara